in questa città quando caro salve
aspetta che non trovo il joystick color
guarda avanti tieni premuto option
sicuro nuova partita meno principale
mica con un menù così il gioco può
accompagnare sono
mezzanotte e vorrei detto ruby ma io ci
ho 22 anni oa dormire alle 3 del mattino
ma ma questo ha detto che a mezzanotte
devo andare a dormire non è vero
sono morto gesù 6 su questa non è gesù
però delle belle bocce zia anche tu sei
molto bella in spagna moschino ma no no
non voglio entrare era ben rosso cosa
top difficili comasca tocchi oddio oddio
meglio come mi muovo cos'è perché perché
mi prendono tutte
volevo toccarla io non tu al contrario
mazza o mazza è più o meno come la metro
di milano un po più pulita ma io devo
andare avanti di qua va alla fine ho
preso le boe la sola lato carra porta
fighter
fatemi capire un attimo che cosa dovrei
fare perché
salve my name is a dj sono una persona
tranquilla quindi non mi fate del male
perché io sono socievole con le persone
quindi grazie
c'è satana in questo vagone per caso e
vabbè allora [ __ ] ciao frate siamo
tutti calmi che quella situazione si sta
scaldando subito via via di qua vi
arriva veloce scappa corri corri con
cori veloce fatemi capire questa è la
mia velocità massima ma che ha un corpo
morto che piacere permesso al pronto
moda font primi portata una merda
dobbiamo vederli sì sì adesso arrivano
parla poco ma gli scudetti ma cosa e
anima che spacca i piatti cambiate ma
cos'è che conversazioni stupido appena
avuto al telefono shamo spero sia
puntuale sono qua sono quasi a sono
bassano passa corri corri deficiente
sono quasi anno dai perdo la [ __ ] così
via zia zia zia zia di aver fermato per
ma non ci voglio credere
dai l'ho persa ma lezione non entrare su
zio certo scrivi pure non entrare in una
porta mezza aperta
water park
chi è che sono screen l'ex perché c'è
una cucina in una stazione dei treni che
cazzo è come se girassi per milano
centrale trova una cucina va bè ragazzi
se voi sapeste quanto questa cucina in
realtà è più pulita della mia
basta agosto disco il pubblico non
volevo scommetti lo metti lo metti sta
scherzando
scherzavo chi è che ha fatto sto casino
via via via che ha dato stava scherzando
vai vai vai in casacca che ansia
ok ragazzi non sto capendo dove stiamo
andando però l'aveva medico a lipari qua
perfetto
posso vedermi allo specchio ragazzi
siete pronti a vedere il mio bel faccino
ci siete
grazie a gesù cristo quotidiano l'acqua
perfetto abbasso gli sprechi
cazzo c'è il basilisco nelle tubature
via via via via via piano ce n'è
un'altra o ringraziando gesù stiamo
uscendo
io non ce la facevo più guarda
ma qua non siamo a napoli pelli questi
televisori moderni che vendono non c'è
nessuno qua
secondo te in mente tutta sta merda
trova un telefono che bello eccolo
eccolo pronto a figura dimmi perché si
tornata perché c'è la mamma butta è lo
so anch'io ma chi ha concluso frate
fratelli cos'è successo
non capisco da dove arriva a cesana ciao
dana aspetta aspetta quanti problemi
questa domina scarico l'italia per ora
ragazze questa roba questa roba della
brandon vista veramente sfuggendo di
mano corato che leggono basta però è
provato che raduna cote ora ci sia è
laggiù laggiù la vedo lo vedo perché per
di che a voi telefono con me a punto ma
che sono un deficiente quindi bella li
va a van goof comunque non è possibile
pure la struttura della città ci si
mette in mezzo per per farmi perdonare
ma porca eva quanti problema per provare
a girarla di qua io comunque non ho
veramente capito come diavolo è
possibile che tipo cos'è progressi
salvati concediti una pausa rivolgiti
avanti la [ __ ] prima di tutto veloci vai
vai continuiamo veloci veloci veloce che
la passerà qui
la passera qua ulula non abbiamo mai
capito non ho veramente capito dov'è
andato a finire la zia family due o tre
precipizi in questa città quando capì si
sono cagato in mano fortissimo ormai me
lo aspettavo altarolo è un attimo ma
cos'era uno fa la pausa descrivono gli
obiettivi tranquille faina pausa e poi
riprendi e poi ti fanno saltare addosso
la stile efficienti calmo
macché
via di quadra
bene non me l'aspettavo proprio però va
bene così
c'è stata nella luce satana
andiamo da satana mi sembrava un buon
momento per andare da satana ciao
cestaro santo iddio ciao piacere questo
si sta facendo un self è rimasto così
secondo me dietro sta porta c'è il
demonio però è altro nascita entro entra
in quanto premesso che kakà bene secondo
me la tua ragazza ti tradisce via via
via veloce veloce veloce che si gira
però sa che si gira però ski si gira
veloce
bye bye bye bye vaghe non si butta giù o
non si fa lo dico la polizia vandalo
banda lo schifoso
e poi c'è lo dico alla polizia che stavi
pisciando su un cadavere
brutta la tua sorella lercia in
autostrada perché dovete fare queste
cose di puzza la madre ciao sei prove
dubstep passo grazie non li seguiamo che
dite regalino di seguire poco io andrei
dalla parte opposta perfetto grazie
bene molto bene
che bello questo gioco mi piace un sacco
o i cavi in fibra ottica tutto parallela
trama di questo gioco seguire la fibra
ottica va dove ti porta al internet
portante quello ecco ma eseguire
l'internet che un posto brutto progressi
salvati concediti una pausa ma stavolta
ti do ragione o quasi sfiorato un
infarto prima va bene ragazzi basta
qualcuno qui episodio di fear daylights
proprio stato guarda preferito giocare
in nero indeciso se giocare a questo
cooking mama ha vinto questo pensate che
culo congrega soli sparavieri sia
piaciuto con quello che l'episodio la
sete ragazzi servito piaciuto solo
commento è un mi piace anche ai vari
social che come notato né descrizione se
authority di settore ci limitiamo ad un
prossimo vino ragazzi